forecasters predict an above-normal
hurricane season which is devastating
news for one community in Louisiana
that's already disappearing under the
water Isle de Jean Charles a small
island off the coast has lost more than
90 percent of its land over the last 60
years over 90 percent in our eye on
Earth series Malaya via al got a rare
look at the huge challenges facing the
Islanders Mita yet please tell us
there's a plan in place to help these
people hey well good morning look there
is no doubt that this island is
disappearing quickly both federal and
state governments are stepping in to
help resettle the less than 60 people
still living there but the project is
two years in and not a single family has
agreed to move because they just don't
trust that this is the right thing to do
the history of Isle de Jean Charles is
as rich as the oil siphon from
Louisiana's Gulf Coast once home to
hundreds of Native American families
it's now quickly disappearing and so are
the tribes that once lived here yeah you
can see the water long way right up here
you know people are still cleaning up
after Hurricane Berry hit in early July
as a weak category one storm people
gonna need a lot of help to rebuild and
stuff you notice it's just heartbreaking
when Barry blew through this area the
road here was completely washed away and
all the residents had decided not to
evacuate had to be rescued by Coast
Guard the islands natural barriers are
being eaten away by intruding saltwater
from the Gulf and the state's levee
project protects most in Louisiana
southern coast but leaves the island out
why were you guys left out of that we
have no idea this is the only business
Laura and Jason belongs to the Houma
tribe and owns the only business left on
the island back in 2016 a federal grant
worth 48 million dollars was awarded to
the state of Louisiana for a
resettlement project that would move
anyone off the island to a new community
nearly 40 miles north but not everyone
is happy that this is the only solution
do you feel like there's some distrust
in how the project is happening oh it's
definitely distrust I mean
you talking to native people and
government and so I've never known them
to have a trusted relationship and
there's no different with this project
when you hear people referred to the
tribe and also to this island as
America's first climate change refugees
that's such an insult why were just
we're not no refugees I mean our people
has been discriminated over and over
again and to say that it's just so
disrespectful yeah everybody you people
were living back there back in the 70s
Steve billiot a local shrimper took us
out on the bayou
all around us we saw what was once
Louisiana land now it's a lost world
surrounded by trees stuck in the sea
like Forks this all used to be land and
this is part of it I mean this land
right here we took the 40 mile trip
inland to see the proposed site Pat
Forbes is the executive director of the
resettlement project how many people are
signing on the dotted line we haven't
asked anybody to sign on a dotted line
yet there are supposed to be a hundred
and fifty homes built here by 2022 but
so far only 27 families have shown
interest nobody wants to leave the
island but they recognized for the most
part that they're not going to be able
to live there forever this island once
boasted more than 22,000 acres struck by
the consequences of climate change today
it measures around 320 acres with just
35 structures deliverable how does it
make you feel when you see the land
that's belonged to your family like
literally being washed away that's hard
I mean to see what's been done and it's
out of their hands if it's it saddens me
to see that mm-hmm if anyone decides to
resettle and leave they won't lose
ownership of their homes but they can't
make improvements or money on them
meanwhile a storm system could develop
in the Gulf this weekend bringing half a
foot of rain which could bring more
flooding to the Isle de Jean Charles
it's just so horrible what these people
have to face every day I know a lot of
the concern all
so is on dredging from the oil and gas
industry which is huge there and that is
something that is compounding the
climate change problems it definitely is
look we're looking at climate change
here right we're looking at Tull water
intrusion we're looking at rising sea
levels but also I mean there was a levee
project that was constructed there that
leaves them out that's part of the issue
and also the dredging yes is so it's
compounded on this poor island in any
case the clock is ticking for those
folks Maria that absolutely